le passage à la monnaie unique c'est
déjà une réalité pour les petits
commerçants qui depuis le milieu de la
semaine ont reçu leurs premiers fonds de
caisse en euros bien sûr une façon de se
familiariser ou plutôt de s'entraîner à
rendre la monnaie unique
martin ouest en sortant de sa banque le
regard inquiet philippe kowalcyk forte
un paquet inhabituel philippe tient une
mercerie à la courneuve il est allé
chercher son premier fonds de caisse en
euros l'âge est l'équivalent de 6 euros
soit vinyle et en rentrant à la boutique
familiale
il faut de nouveau vérifié que le compte
est bon c'est à dire que toutes les
pièces sont là il n'y a pas encore de
billet dans la caisse
mais pour philippe ce n'est pas un
problème le 1er janvier quand je vais
ouvrir
je vais commencer à vendre la monnaie en
euros contre une valeur française sans
un range de vilain t on chaque fois des
petites sommes et pour rendre ces
petites sommes sans se tromper philippe
va profiter des 24 prochains jours pour
s'habituer à la nouvelle monnaie arlette
sa mère compte sur lui pour éviter les
erreurs qu'en tant que ménagères pour
aller faire mes courses se sont
tellement confiance aux commerçants là
je n'ai absolument pas peur mais d'être
vise la clientèle c'est un autre regard
et là j'aurais vraiment peur de me
tromper j'ai dit que pendant les deux
mois je ne rendrai pas la monnaie
pourtant pionnier dans leur quartier
philippe et sa mère ont dû attendre plus
que prévu pour recevoir leur nouveau
fond de quête
comme de nombreux commerçants ce n'est
que quelques jours avant les
particuliers qu'ils peuvent manier
l'euro